all right
[Applause]
happy tuesday everyone you all look
fantastic
almost as good as me
that'll never happen
but that's serious topic tonight every
monday we usually cover the previous
weekend's violence it's another thing
we've gotten used to tracking like
inflation or how often biden loses a
fight with gravity
but now it's like how many has been shot
how many dead it's like doing a weather
report and in chicago it means whether
you survive the weekend
a little word play there
cause lately it's been nothing but
storms of violence accompanied by a hail
of bullets as of today five major u.s
cities are on track to break their
already impressive homicide figures
kudos go out to la dc baltimore
milwaukee and atlanta where the cost of
living rises with your chance of dying
it wasn't easy but they gave it all they
had to surpass last year's numbers truly
a team effort the mayors and the thugs
pulled together to surpass last year's
great season
meanwhile california governor gavin
newsom blames republicans since murders
happen in red states ignoring that most
homicides occur in cities run by
democrat idiots like himself
it's amazing what hair gel can do to the
brain
i look at newsome and i worry about
jesse
least jesse's hair products come from
fox newsome buys his off the street from
a guy who robbed a walgreens
the media does its normal
job defining it as gun violence like
guns just show up on their little
adorable gun legs
they blame the weapon and not the guy
who points and fires aka the alec
baldwin approach
for the dems they couldn't give a crap
either unless it can help them
politically then they give more poops
than 50 pigeons on a statue
it's the worst combo people in charge
unaffected by their own policies that
means it can continue you can point out
the insane murder rates in liberal
cities but you know what libs tell me
they don't see it so it really doesn't
exist
well in that case who cares let's get
dinner and drinks tonight right don we
went out had a great dinner in new york
city tonight people actually walked up
to us and said thank you for i watch you
every night i haven't played that one in
a while
i wonder if they still died together
it's got to be awkward
but it's true crime only occurs in
certain parts of the city
you know just like how the bathroom's
only part of your home
but when the toilet overflows you'll
soon have a problem everywhere
of course when dems can't go to dinner
anymore because it's unsafe they'll just
order in and let the delivery man dodge
the bullets
no wonder they want open borders you
need people willing to die to get your
pad thai
yeah
thank you very proud of that one
[Applause]
shouldn't think about it for a while
it's odd though this indifference
playing out among the people who pretend
to care it's like watching a serial
killer nurse poisoning her patients they
spent days rehashing january 6 for
political benefit instead of helping
their constituents survive but the
suspects on jan 6 were the right kind of
villain which makes the media's job so
much easier so how did this get so bad
well i bet it's the progressive left
going in the other direction
the progressive left is going in the
other direction they are effectively
enabling the criminals with the uh the
reforms that they put in place and in
many respects disarming the police
unless they get smart and turn it around
uh they're going to get wiped out in
november certainly in a couple of years
down the line they'll get wiped out in
elective offices at the state and local
level because the fear is going to grow
and as the crime is growing
so finally they're talking about crime
on msnbc
although the only way for them to care
is to prey on their political fears
rather than focus on the growing
mountain of victims who are mostly black
white wild black men and boys ages 15 to
34 make up just two percent of the
nation's population they were among 37
percent of gun homicides that year
that's 20 times higher than white males
at the same of the same age group so
what do dem say about that well you know
it's just gang on gang stuff it's like
mafia violence as long as you steered
clear you're fine but what about those
in the crossfire kids moms shopkeepers
people leaving a bar bouncers cops all
lives ended by a stray bullet remember
the old newscaster line they were just
in the wrong place at the wrong time
well now the wrong place is a park
playground and the wrong time is two in
the afternoon on a wednesday
and what about the black males who could
have had a different opportunity what
about their families who've lost a son
father or brother the progressive d.a
solution decriminalized gun crime
meaning if you're caught with a gun we
just confiscate it and then we turn you
loose but i guess they want to focus on
the real threats parents who ask school
boards why there's a drag queen twerking
on the librarian's desk
[Laughter]
so we live in two countries and the left
is cool with it and we can't talk about
it because that's racist but if we can't
talk about it we can't solve it
so who's stopping us well i'll give you
a tiny tiny hint
let's start with teachers unions the
wardens of these prisons we call schools
we're sentencing poor blacks to a life
of bad education so it's hard to blame
them seeking other options and it's all
brought to you by teachers unions who
hate school choice because it's
competition
so now we're told reading math and
history are racist to be replaced with
pronoun workshops and grievance studies
you rob kids of the skills they need to
succeed and in a few years those kids
will rob you
at least they'll get a person's pronoun
correct during a carjacking
that's progress
[Applause]
tonight's guess
she's just another slap who won't
tolerate liberal crap former white house
strategic communications director
mercedes slap
he's so dapper his pocket square has a
pocket square
i'm not kidding this time that's pure
steersucker
hosa making money on fox business
charles payne
and
you may recognize him from carrying rob
schneider's luggage
yeah anyway actor
writer and comedian jamie lisa
[Applause]
and finally she's like a shell casing
tiny brassy and often found at crime
scenes
fox's contributor captive
charles welcome to the show we're both
wearing uh
fuchsia is this fuchsia purple ties
uh i you know when it comes to colors
i'm in the seven crayon box i grew up
they invent new ones all the time i
don't know you know so it's in the
purple family yes exactly apparently we
should have called earlier and worked
this thing out i feel like there's like
and maybe i'm wrong because i have been
wrong in the past rarely i feel like
there's an implicit agreement between
politicians people in power and like
perpetrators you keep it to yourself in
your neck of the woods and we'll look
the other way like in chicago as long as
you know if if you don't as long as you
stay in this side and you don't come
over here we're going to basically let
it go is that am i crazy no you're not
crazy ironically in chicago uh you know
some people say one of the reasons it's
even gotten worse is because the
gentrification the the black
neighborhoods have gotten smaller on the
hispanic neighborhoods have actually
shrunk so the turf wars are more
intensified and again they look the
other way you know you can get away with
certain things i got to tell you
growing up in harlem i mean i witnessed
murders
attempted murders
um
and you always knew someone would either
a not go to jail or go to jail for a
very short period of time and this was
in the 70s yeah so this has been around
for a long time blaming guns
instead that person
you know and i love what you said about
the education system because that really
is the root of it from the very
beginning these subpar watered down bs
educations that essentially is saying we
think you're too dumb
and so we're not going to pressure you
you know you'll read dick and jane all
the way to sixth grade and by the time
you're in 12th grade and you're about
four or five grades behind we'll make
you a faustian deal you won't be able to
compete in this society but if you vote
for us forever we'll give you housing
projects we'll give you more food stamps
we'll do this for you and that for you
it's just it's it's nuts it's worked for
the democrats for decades uh i think i
think it's starting to fade a little bit
with younger generations i think people
are starting to see through this
older generations it kind of works and
that's why clyburn was able to elevate
biden then because older folks remember
when it was really really tough right
younger people were saying hey
i want to start a crypto mining company
you know so so it's it's not working
like it did before right right right
that's basically school is basically a
holding can
for kids
you know
jamie
jamie do they have crime in alaska and
is it committed mostly by bears
it's a lot we have a lot of bear on bear
crime
as long as they keep it in their colony
yeah then who cares right yeah exactly
it is weird how different our laws are
though like even common laws like cell
phone driving laws or whatever like in
alaska it's different we have a law that
states if you're
if you're talking on your cell phone and
you're driving and you see a policeman
you have to put your phone down for a
second
that's the law
yeah that is the law isn't it just so
much bad news though man like i feel
like every time i come back it's like
more and more crime and and in these big
cities i just want to say like so many
murders and stuff i want to say if
anybody is sees that i'm performing in
any of these cities if you want to come
out to my show i promise an entire hour
where there will be no killing
just let you sit on that one
yeah
you're now are you spending more time in
new york are you worried when you're
here i'm not worried i i don't mind uh i
don't know i'm honestly it's like
i worry more about did you notice that
like you walk down the street and you
can buy i want to know what's going on
with like the weed situation here like
it is so crazy you can just hand out is
that a legal thing or is it that they're
doing it and no one's enforcing it i
don't know i don't know i don't even
know what you're talking about
it's no clue and so we're great people i
have no idea what's weed we
generally we you know we go to the
church yeah and we put usually before
and then we help the kids the orphans
this weed business is not our purview
well going to church is like the time
that we for ourselves yes exactly
because we're so busy helping the kids
yeah helping the kids so i think you
know what if you want to talk about your
crazy pot stuff you take it somewhere
else
hippie hippie mercedes
if you look at how liberal mayors are
dealing with crime you think they were
on the kkk payroll because it's
basically oh you know
they don't care that blacks are killing
each other like that it's just insane
like and that they could just assume
it's gang stuff yeah and these liberal
mayors i mean it's all about identity
politics for them but it's the uh the
identity politics of taking down the
cops uh their goal is to demoralize
demonize these cops that's why you've
seen so many of these police officers
leave their their line of work and
really not be able to serve these
communities and i think for the
democrats i just don't get it because
they're going to get crushed in the poll
in these next elections because the
polls are showing that crime and public
safety seem to be two of the top issues
right now and i got to tell you i mean i
hope jamie's putting on his ticket stub
that you know killing is not going to be
part of his show i think that's going to
be a helpful thing but i think it's
usually word of mouth word of mouth no
killing no killing yeah but uh i think
for the democrats it's it's definitely a
big loss for them but really charles
talked about education it's about the
family at the end of the day that is the
core when you have destabilized family
structures where the parents are not
there for the children or even the
grandparents that in and of itself and
we can't even talk about fatherless
anymore because you can't talk about
father or mother only on father's day
can you talk about fathers and you know
it really that's the centerpiece of it
as well we can rely on the education
system but it starts at the house to be
able to really build
up can't do anything about the house
that's like the first four to five years
if you don't do something before 16 then
it's gone so it's kind of like if you at
least if we can just get them sooner
before they they're out of high school
that might help maybe just getting them
out of the womb would be a good place to
start
speaking
um
cat i want to bring uh your you've been
watching the supreme court uh very
closely uh since the early 70s so they
ruled today that preventing school
choice families from taking their kids
uh taxpayer-funded education dollars to
religious private schools violated the
free exercise clause of the first
amendment meaning i mean that meaning
that they're backing school choice yeah
of course it does yeah see i could be a
supreme court justice i'd say this
like
you're really lucky to have me sitting
right here when i could be on the
bench exactly exactly what's your
solution
well i think that
all these people wouldn't really have to
try that hard
to learn from their mistakes which says
to me that they must be trying to not
learn right because you just have to pay
a little bit of attention to know that
this isn't working because they know
that it's failing yes it's important to
hold police accountable but you also
need to hold criminals accountable
realize that property crimes are not
victimless i realize that violent
criminals are not the types of people
who deserve leniency right uh but
um having to notice that they failed and
admit that they failed would have to be
the first step to doing something
different and apparently that's more
important to them than
bloodshed on the streets which i think i
have different priorities yeah you that
you do and it's definitely i'm staunchly
anti-bloodshed yeah yeah yeah and it has
we have no interest in this thing called
weed
no
jamie why do you bring this poisonous
talk it's honestly insulting to me yes
and my integrity to talk like that in
front of a lady such as i yeah
i'll tell you what what made me think of
it is like i don't know if the pandemic
hit anybody else like i gained like a
little bit of weight during the day and
it go
and it and it goes i swear i did edibles
every night for two years
but you know what it wasn't just weed it
was just things that were edible
on that we might get a move up next
they're yelling ships ahoy but don't
assume they're a girl or a boy
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else